Carl M cannon author of the pursuit of
happiness in times of war what gave you
an idea that this would be a book well
brian i didn't i didn't know it was a
book right away but i had been asked by
a magazine forbes magazine to do a piece
about the living presence they were
doing an end-of-the-year thing on the
pursuit of happiness they said could you
interview some of the ex-presidents or
get them to write and so I did that and
it was a funny thing I'd heard president
say you know life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness a hundred times
probably I never really thought much
about it like most Americans and but
then 911 came and I had this stuff in
the can these interviews I i emailed
george HW bush bush 41 said you know do
you want to change anything you wrote
it's going to look kind of maybe
frivolous and he wrote back and said no
no i don't and he'd written about his
happiness of his personal life and his
wife and his kids and he'd taking pride
in them and i thought i thought there's
something there I didn't know what it
was and then after nine eleven remember
Rudy Giuliani and Bush sort of emerged
as these commanding figures but before
nine eleven they Bush had been as
marginal a present as a president can be
absent a scandal and Giuliana had made
himself into something of a joke
suddenly within hours in Giuliani's case
and he'd emerged as a hero and within
days and bushes casey's emerges this
forceful wartime president and I thought
all right what did they do to transform
themselves what were they saying what
they were saying was anjuli nice case he
was telling Americans to go to the
theater and go shopping and Bush was
telling people to go to baseball games
and Disney World he even said that once
and I thought are they what is this are
they missing the boat and so then I
began looking into this this language of
the preamble which both those men cited
the pursuit of happiness Americans right
to pursue their heart's content even
during war and I wondered if these two
were right or if they were all wet
historically and I just thought
looking to did Forbes publish the
article Borges did publish the article
and what what was the data it was you
know December of 2001 and it was great
it was all kinds of leaders not just
presents but all kinds of people and and
that it was Forbes ASAP it was mostly a
you know business sort of pursuing your
happiness your dreams and
entrepreneurship is what their thing but
the president's interested me at this
point much more than business leaders
and so I began to look at all the
wartime presence back to really well
even back to Jefferson and even George
Washington had you ever thought about
the Declaration of Independence at any
great link no not really like a lot of
Americans I think I that languages out
there and I like it but I had never
really even written about it where does
it come in the decoration well it's
right it's the preamble I carry it
around with me since nine eleven you
know it's right here it's the very
beginning can I read you the first
couple of sentence sure when in the
course of human events it becomes
necessary for one people to dissolve the
political bands which have connected
them with another and to assume among
the powers of the earth the separate and
equal station which the laws of nature
nature's God entitle them a decent
respect to the opinions of mankind
requires that they should declare the
causes which impel them to the
separation and then Jefferson starts the
cost is we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal and that they are endowed that
they are endowed by their creator with
certain unalienable rights that among
these are life liberty the pursuit of
happiness and that's so the preamble is
only you know the beginning of the
Declaration and I only take the
beginning of the preamble and build my
book around what those words mean to
americans and I wartime presidents and
other national leaders and times of
crisis have used those words to
galvanize America when did forbes
magazine specifically come to you what
was the date you remember as summer
maybe spring of 2001 so before September
the right what got them interested in
well they just said I think they do it
this was an end-of-the-year project that
they were doing and they were looking
for a freelancer to help them I'd
written some stuff for them I you know I
cover the White House full-time as you
know
and for National Journal they're very
good about letting me do an occasional
project like this so Forbes called they
were just interested they were just
kicking it around they have no of course
inkling but those were to take on a
greater meaning very soon when they came
to you did you consider yourself a happy
person and do you consider yourself a
happy person now yeah I do i do that
maybe that's just ignorance on my part
but yeah the last paragraph in your book
a native of San Francisco Carl attended
the University of Colorado majoring in
journalism he lives in arlington
virginia he and his wife Sharon have
three children ranging in ages from
eight to twenty two Carl pursues
pursuits include fly fishing in Montana
thoroughbred racing opera and playing
amateur baseball in an adult hardball
league does that say at all you see how
my job gets in the way of my life I'd
have does it but I love my work remember
Phil Burton you remember Phil the
freshman year from San Francisco every
time I call I came to Washington and he
was like my godfather though Phil
wouldn't particularly religious or
Catholic but and he would he caught I
called him and he said anytime you need
me you know call me because we're old
family friends I never really did call
him and I feel bad about it because Phil
died young but every time I talk to me
to always say are you happy in your work
and I realized that that's really the
key thing those other things are great
fun but if you're not happy in your work
you know how much of a shot this I have
a chapter unhappiness on what happiness
is at some point in the book I felt
probably should have done it earlier in
the book but I did late in the book wait
a minute what is happiness and so I did
research into the most current social
science and it's it's it's what you
might think money does not make people
happy richest and wealth does not make
people happy how do you know well
there's their studies people there
people who at these universities are
this is what they do David Myers is one
there's there's others but what does
make people happy what but very
destitute people aren't happy either I
can't
happy really Eleanor Roosevelt right
talked about this and I quote her but
for people in modern America to be happy
they they have to have a sense that
their work means something and that
they're listening to in the workplace
and that they're contributing to society
these are very reassuring things to find
out so the article was published was
your reaction to it yeah I don't know so
how do you get to the book though oh
well I by this time I had more I wanted
to say a lot more and Larry Sabato the
University of Virginia another person
you know called me up and said I'm doing
this series of books on American
political challenges what he and what
he's really doing is trying to line up
writers for this publisher rowman &
littlefield and do you have anything
that you think you could write about
American political challenges I said
Larry just so happens I do have
something and I told him the outline of
this book over the phone and then in an
email and he forwarded to Roman little
field and they they loved it and of
course it goes against I mean my
father's written many books and all my
friend said that's totally not the way
to do you have to get an agent after
this you have to do that and this was an
academic publisher who gave up pretty
small advance but by then I just wanted
I had something I wanted to do I had
something I wanted to say i just threw
myself into it your father is Lou cannon
who is well II long time reporter for
The Washington Post and biographer of
Ronald Reagan he also wrote he's written
other books including official
negligence the book on the riots in Los
Angeles and he's a he said I mean I
don't he's a great man and a great
writer you know him
and say he's one of the few that have
had a two-hour booknotes is that right
did Ronald Reagan years ago go back to
fill Burton congressman filbert imac rat
from San Francisco brother John still
out there still in politics in
Sacramento how did you how are you have
family friends my parents my mother and
father worked precincts for fill in the
mid 50s and literally I was campaigning
for fill in a pram I was months old I
wasn't doing much work but my mother was
she was handing out things strolling me
up the streets of San Francisco and so
my family has a long connection with the
Burton's my mother's native of San
Francisco my dad moved there when he was
a young man he's from Nevada and they
met there how did you get into
journalism and I mean it's obvious
course your dad was in about how you
don't necessarily always good minds
around yeah my parents didn't go into
politics as it happens though they might
they fooled around in politics when they
were young but by the time my father got
out of the army and got a job driving a
truck and turns out what he'd always
wanted to do all his life is be a
reporter and he became one and I grew up
in that family and never really thought
of politics and i didn't think i was
thinking of journalism until one day I
you know decided to go to journalism
school it it just sort of happened to me
and I've grown up in that biz where'd
you go to school University of Colorado
and along the way how many different
jobs in journalism Oh bunch worked at
newspapers in Petersburg Virginia and
Columbus Georgia and then the San Diego
Union hired me and then San Jose Mercury
News and they sent me here I was a
knight ridder bureau for ten years and
then the Baltimore Sun covered the first
five years of the Clinton administration
and the National Journal offered me a
job in 1998 and I I was wanting to do
magazine work it was a fortuitous thing
national journal is just a great place
for me
I want you to take us to a night you're
at the Correspondents Dinner the white
house correspondents dinner and you're
now the president of the way let's go
yesterday you're seated next to the
president announced States George W Bush
right and you're in pursuit of
information for this book set up the
whole oh well it's funny I was talking
you don't you're there at the dinner and
you know you talk about everything and
the rules of it the ground rules are
sort of unstated you know this is a
great secret i don't know if it's on the
record off the record and you know but
you know not not to ask because of
course the president say well of course
it's off the record and we r time in
he'll talk he said he's like clinton in
that really good conversationalist he'll
talk but two hours a long time we talked
about baseball talked about this we
talked about that at some point i talked
about this book he had the funniest
reaction right I've never printed this
they were about tell you he said that
sounds about wartime presidents and he
had been asking me about Roosevelt he's
very interested in FDR and he said well
I'd read that I said well mr. president
you're in it and he kind of laughed for
a minute like oh yeah guess I am but it
was a fun in what way I mean did did he
know how he was in and I know I mean
what did you gotten from him up till
that point well I had you know we were
talking about really I was in the sort
of final throes I wasn't really
interviewing for the book I had gotten
some quotes from him earlier in the
process and I'd read all his speeches
and I was I was sort of doing what you
do i was running by him his thesis about
the pursuit of happiness and how and how
human rights and if you if you follow my
book follows the point that the thesis
of my book is that is that though if
this country has a something a special
mission if american exceptionalism is
alive and well that mission is extending
Jefferson's unalienable rights to people
who do not yet have them
and this book chronicles how presidents
have wrestled with that all the
presidents before Lincoln who knew that
slavery was wrong even the slaveholders
but knew that it would take a war to end
it and finally Lincoln war was foisted
on Lincoln but he didn't shrink from it
beginning with African slaves and ending
with in my book with the Kurds northern
Iraq when this country is doing what it
should be doing and doing it well it's
extending these rights to others I
talked to Bush about that and he didn't
say a lot but he he clearly was
intrigued by that idea i had already
spoken about it you know Bush himself
has spoken about this pretty clearly and
if that if those rights are unalienable
Jefferson's rights are unable well then
it's the philosophical corollary is that
the desire for them is universal which
clearly believes that he said so many
times by the way but when you're sitting
and very few people ever sit next to
president for two hours in conversation
what do you get and from sitting next
what did you take away from that that we
may not get just watching him on
television well I mean is he a happy man
oh yeah yeah he is and he's also he's
funny and he's just very human he's very
down to earth John F Kennedy once
observed that the presidency is not a
normal ambition but and you think of
them with some removing and and if
Kennedy said that I mean that means it's
not the ambition of normal people so
these people they all have big egos now
but the other thing is when you talk to
them it's always a surprise how human
they are I mean Bush at some point we
had to entertainment he asked me kind of
how long just going to go on and he said
you know I've got the dish set I was
hoping to get home and watched a little
the ranger game tonight yes he has sort
of concerns like you and I have and that
to me is reassuring I don't know if
everyone would find it reassuring I took
away from you in here and tell me if I'm
right that you are personally
philosophically for what happened in
Iraq well I I was very leery of it and I
because I was covering it I didn't
express any opinions but I think I had
misgivings I I think I thought it was
perilous and very difficult but but once
that's undertaken I think it's probably
good for the world if if the if a
democracy emerges in Iraq I i I'm I was
agnostic before but I'm not now I'm
really pulling for this thing to work
and I you know you talked to I have dear
friends were Democrats um we were
working on these campaigns against bush
and at some point after the day is over
and we're having a beer I said look it's
helped more helpful to you if this thing
turns south and Iraq but you must
realize it's better for the country
better for the world if it doesn't and
they privately say yeah I mean if the
price if Iraq turns out great and the
prices we lose the presidential election
that's probably worth it so I don't
think most thoughtful people really
disagree with that one the question on
the President Bush do you get any sense
that he knows anything about history
he's always criticized in some quarters
for not being curious you know what
that's funny those are two slightly
different questions they are very
curious how much he knows is an open
question he may get found him to ask you
a question yeah and you know he gave an
interview to Britt human which is sort
of boasted about not reading the
newspapers he said something along those
lines to me that night but differently
he said he doesn't read editorials and
op-eds he doesn't read the columnist to
attack him and I mean he's in good
company George Washington didn't either
and the one time Henry Knox brought him
a cartoon why she's had a tantrum at a
cat eating a tirade so which doesn't
want to have tirades and he wants to
stay positive but when he says he
doesn't read the news at all that's not
reassuring um think it's true I don't
know I don't know he um but he's curious
and he so he's open-minded in a way that
in person that he doesn't come across
and these speeches I mean he the people
he asked me about for instance were all
Democrats pump for he's very interested
in Hubert Humphrey Humphreys a closet
hero of my book
politics of joy yeah exactly did you
know everyone I didn't and my father did
I didn't know him but Humphrey used to
give these speeches in which he would
say you know America is the only country
where the pursuit of happiness is
guaranteed and he would open his
speeches like I mean it was a big thing
to him and he wasn't it wasn't phony he
really was the happy warrior a phrase
that was of course applied to Al Smith
and FDR but they never fit anybody
better than Hubert by the way when you
had your conversation with President
Bush and it's not established what the
ground rules are did you go back home
and write it all down no I've been urged
to do that by friends I've been too busy
I should have done that I didn't do that
alright let's jump to Plains Georgia
yeah what's that's Jimmy Carter yeah
what's that story well you know Carter
said some of the most evocative things
about the pursuit of happiness what in
fact he in his farewell speech to the
nation use this language life liberty
the pursuit of penis and sort of put it
in a modern context what it would mean
environmentalism is one of the things it
would mean in helping the nation's the
world's poor and Carter had a very and
Carter had some thoughtful things to say
but this was old this was nineteen
eighty-one and so I'm writing twenty
years later and I think well I wonder if
he still feels that way so I tried to
get into by the way 81 he's out of the
present zero yeah well he's leaving yeah
he was well he was it was a to know it
was January of 81 it was when he was
leaving so is this farewell speech I
think it was a few days into January may
have been late December but that's the
time period and then again at the 84
Democratic convention he gives his
speech and he says these things
modernizing Jefferson's language and in
a way that's compelling but i thought
well does he still hold with this and
now after the attacks what we have
something extra to say and
it Carter has always been hard to deal
with his operation yo you call and can
you get interview well maybe and it went
on for some months and fine just but I'm
going down there and he speaks in his
church semi-regularly and I went down or
just on the happenstance he would be
there any was the Baptist Church and
planes de maranatha baptist church in
Plains Georgia Carter gives what they
call a Sunday School but what what am I
what I my tradition we would call the
Bible study really but Carter comes out
in them days he's there with his wife
and he explains to the people what he's
been doing in the previous week or month
and it's always a lot he goes around the
world monitoring elections he's with
Habitat for Humanity Emmys his whole
life is public service and mission and
then and then he has a Bible lesson of
the day he really knows his Bible as
much as I mean it's very impressive so I
sit in the front row ebay so I was by
myself yeah it was actually sitting by a
person I met who's a high school teacher
from Florida had come up for the event
man I didn't know I should send him this
book was in time frame of that by the
way what year this October of 2001 two
years two years ago roughly minogue our
october november and you're there
because you can't get to him right right
and i think value but i don't i'll be
content to asking this one question do
you still stand by these words you wrote
that's the only mission you're after and
at some point he looked at me I've met
Carter once or twice I wouldn't think
he'd remember me buddy I must look like
a reporter because he kind of looked at
me and he didn't smile this was during
his lecture and after it's over he and
his wife meet every person that comes
under these shade trees out and back and
they if you want your picture made they
stand there over the picture it's very
gracious and I waited to the line when I
was the last person lasted listen on and
he sort of cut me off is it yeah some
reporter come he said something like
do that at church I said well mr.
president church is over and anyway I've
come a very long way to ask you one
question and question him was a wall it
is it ok snappish I so what does this
thing I pull out these papers I was a
little flustered i guessing to drop him
on the ground so well it's about the
pursuit of happiness and you said some
things I want to ask you if he's still
he's soften and he said we're on it's
about something I wrote it what's the
harm of it he said just would you mind
waiting over there any sort of directed
me and I waited until he finished up
with the last few people and then he
came over and he sort of dropped the
armor and he was very nice and eats and
he said yes that he did what he said
then was his relevant in 2001 as it was
in 1981 and that these attacks had not
changed that and he said you know there
are always new challenges aren't there
and then he spoke about his faith for a
while and it wasn't it was no earth
shattering revelation but it allowed me
to make this connection that I was
trying to make with these presents to
make sure that I was on the right
wavelength you know the fact that this
book idea of mine was right and my
exchange with Carter assured me that it
was you you flew from Washington to
Atlanta and drove a car down oh yeah how
long did that whole process take just to
get this ah you know took a couple of
days you had to go down the night before
was it worth it was absolutely worth it
again correct me if i'm wrong i don't
think you wrote a negative word in here
about a president mmm well I didn't
mention Nixon well but I mean that the
point I'm making is that everything it
may be positive maybe maybe not and I
just want to know if that's conscious
yeah i'm trying to think is that right
that may be right i their slopes if it
it's close there's some things in
Wilson's first term that I don't think
he quite got this but in the second term
he does and yeah that is that is
conscious you know I we you know I live
in a time now where the discourse in
this city is seems angry an extreme it's
not the first time it's happened it's
that happens in cycles but I find in
looking at this that the partisan issues
that seems so big at the time don't seem
big now and they don't and they don't
even seem big to the people to the
players years later no Bob Dole and Bill
Clinton are doing TV shows together in
lectures together Adams and Jefferson
their campaign against each other 200
years ago you know was maybe the meanest
ever we've may never surpassed it may be
72 I don't know but they became very
close friends and and so these ish in
and what I'm writing about I'm looking
for something different a different tone
I'm looking for how these Democrats and
Republican presence sort of rally their
countrymen and they all have much more
in common to me for my purposes than
they have differences and so yeah i'm
i'm stressing yeah that is deliberate I
was like I hope that it's a tone that
more people would adopt its it seems we
get a little breathless how did you
relate to Gerald Ford well Ford there
were two of them I knew actually had
some relationship with before I started
this and Ford was one of them and Bill
Clinton was the other cover Clinton for
eight years and he knows me were we're
not friends but we're not adversaries he
always treated me with respect and I
covered is you know at some point we'll
had to cover impeachment but I mostly
wrote about issues and Clinton likes
that and even if you write a critical
story on an issue he'll he can he can
handles that will he likes the
give-and-take and Ford I had one that
gerald r ford prize for distinguished
reporting of the presidency in for did
come and given the award and so I knew
him and so I called them first and Ford
was just wonderful he so I don't want to
write an essay for you but I'll do an
interview so he calls me up one day in
August hey the weather's great come on
out here I said well where is it he's in
Vail Colorado he was kidding around we
did the interview on the phone and he
was just very down to earth have you
know and John if Kennedy's the caution
about president certainly doesn't apply
to Ford Ford's a very normal guy for
didn't really ever want to be President
so he'd never had that in vicious
and in Carter who's the opposite who had
that mission since he was 16 excuse me
Bill Clinton was also his staff sent
word that he would write something for
me but could it just be on Jefferson
instead of on pursuit of happiness which
was a nice change of pace really you
know usually in the dune areas exact the
exact same question of people and he
wrote something and it was nice and he
surprised his staff by actually making
his deadline he's notorious
procrastinator but it didn't progress
that he he sent the thing right on time
do you write it up oh yeah I'm pretty
sure he did he it yeah it reads like him
so what's your take on all those
presents are they are they all happy I
don't know that that's getting a little
that's getting a little beyond my
purview but I'll say this if you if you
stand as I do I guess this book shows it
that American exceptionalism is alive
and well there is something special
about this country and that we have
something and duties their special you
stand if you if you take that stand you
stand in pretty good company all 43
presidents even Wilson and immigrants
and that's the group those are the group
so through time that I'd be happy to I
think it's pretty good company to keep
and all those prisons have in common
whatever their differences in you know
all they all ran against each other in
succession they all believed that this
country had something special about it
where did those words come from did
Thomas Jefferson actually write them
himself well I spent the longest chapter
nurse trying to figure that out the
short answer is he had a lot of help
these ideas had been out there I mean in
fact I end up going back I gosh i think
you know before Aristotle I mean you
before you go back as far as you want
but the idea that governments are
instituted among men to serve the people
not the other way around predates
monarchies so it's an old idea and the
specific idea of happiness and the
pursuit of happiness this language is
around George Mason wrote it
James Wilson another Virginian wrote
about it Franklin wrote about it so
these words were around these phrases
were around and and so what what
Jefferson did was was borrow this
language synthesized in an era where
that was the expected practice we now
today are very big on original language
and if you borrow language you're a
plagiarist in but in those days the
emphasis was different if you tried to
be totally originally were a show-off
and why would you do that when there was
all this stuff you needed to borrow and
what Jefferson did was build and put it
together now having said all that I'm a
writer Jefferson was the writer and
that's a solitary thing and I was well
he was 33 and two and he went to
Philadelphia with he had the biggest
library I think in the new world he
didn't take a single book that anyone
knows of he goes up there with his
saddlebags and pulls on a piece of paper
now the Virginia Declaration of Rights
that that Mason had written with help
from Jefferson was republished in the
Philadelphia newspaper so Jefferson had
this convenient document and some of the
language about pursuit of happiness is
in there and where was he where did he
write he was in a house called the Jacob
graphs house he rented middle floors of
a house that was if people read the
great do mom alone series they'll say
well the house was destroyed but in fact
since that series ran the house has been
sort of the city fathers in Philadelphia
found out the address and have built a
replica house you could go there and see
have you been there yeah yeah i would go
to the i went to these places it was it
was helpful in a funny way I saw the
desk that he wrote on his in here in
Washington at the National Archives and
I went and looked at that desk and
somehow that helps you mean you mean
Smithsonian yes Susan and the
president's exhibit you mentioned in her
you can go see the desolate wrote these
work yeah what about these words and
that is the desk and Jefferson seems to
have known that that desk would that
people would want to do that because he
he kept that desk didn't keep everything
but he kept that desking for posterity
and it was a sort of self-deprecating
comment about Oh nobody would care but
he knew that they would and in that that
helps to do I don't know why exactly
another person you mentioned the book a
lot is alexis de tocqueville did you
know who he was before you got into this
project oh sure did you read much about
it you know they make you do that in
high school in college but I didn't but
what would I write about de Tocqueville
is how how he how he gets he writes
about this tension between materialism
and altruism and it's still something
that Tocqueville most his countrymen
don't get the French still are
disparaging of us all these years later
but Tocqueville got it there they go
together um and this was this was what
this was what Bush and Giuliani were
doing you know that America's power is
not its wealth but it's it's the power
of these ideas but it America's wealth
allows us to defend those ideas the
technology that we have that we develop
these frightful weapons they allow us to
defend ourselves and in fact go to Iraq
and impose our will if that's what we're
doing and so Tocqueville writes about a
write writes about that and I stumbled
across it actually there was a piece in
The New Yorker by Adam Gopnik and and I
found this and it was sort of like you
know something you dream of was somebody
would find the quote for Ian here's the
dream quote and got Nick founded I I
give him credit I I try to cite
everywhere I got everything um I think I
did that you wrote long footnotes yeah
well those were originally going to be
on the page but my publisher thought
that would be unwieldy but the footnotes
are if anybody buys this book and reads
I would urge interior fit nuts because
they help to help explain where where
I'm getting this stuff I gotta ask you
about one footnote because it just
popped out and it's totally out of
context page 2 99 and you know what
chapter is out to check its chapter 5
it's footnote 11 the pummeled
constituent was a minor league baseball
player named Alexander
n-word age 36 who was promptly arrested
by the Capitol Police senator lods claim
to be too busy to press charges perhaps
the fact was that he was the aggressor
that he was the aggressor meaning Lodge
played a role in his thinking and Ben
were in a fit of patriotism subsequently
enlisted in the United States Army such
were the emotions of the time this story
has been preserved for posterity by the
office of the Senate historian what's
the whole story or his door is the
debate during World War one whether to
enter it and and then as now you know
people were questioning each other's
patriotism we're really people thought
their patriotism was being questioned
maybe it wasn't in lodges case it was
and he's you know whatever he is 65 and
this other guys are athlete and a young
man and catching a lodge knocks him out
you know beats him up in his office
really just really does axiom you know
that we're a little more sophisticated
today about constituent service but and
there's a neat guy and of course the
cops come and they arrest the guy who
gets who has been beaten up its and
how'd you find that little tidbit gosh I
don't remember Brian I I did all this
research I mean cuz ya then that makes
the point this book goes it it's a lot
of territory a lot of history right well
you know what's interesting is how it's
easier to do research now than it was
there's still no substitute and the
greatest storms like James McPherson you
know just go to all these places and
read the letters in their own hand but
for instance the papers of George
Washington have been digitized and you
can you can call them up at your desk
right and when we're done you could go
and call up letters he wrote and their
index and if you know how to search you
search so I as I got into this I would I
never heard of this case of course but
something somehow i came across it then
i went to the Senate archives in there
they are online you took a shot in this
book if I got it correctly at some
historians
yeah and some who have been public and
political well sean wilentz and arthur
schlesinger jr after during impeachment
had this had this petition and you know
the petition was this thing would
eviscerate the power of the presidency
this would yes they sounded like if the
impeachment happened the whole power of
the presidency would be gone and clinton
was impeached and a very close party
line vote virtually party line vote in
the Senate he defeated they are because
impeachment he was not convicted he
served out his term so even after
impeachment there was enough energy in
the executive branch that Clinton was
able to you know do all the things he
was doing see through legislation
appoint judges start a war in kosovo and
a war of liberation in which he
protected people muslim people as it
happens from ethnic cleansing ugly
little euphemism and in fact clinton had
enough energy and executive he even had
another scandal before he left office
the pardons he left office with high
approval ratings and still helped
install his wife in the senate and is
believed by many many democratic
activists that if Gore had al gore had
used him more gore would have won i
don't know if that's true or not we'll
never know that but and so so it seemed
that these historians had been
hysterical and overreacted they never
apologized her to my knowledge so we
were wrong and in fact then when the war
comes in iraq these same people have a
petition oh no no no we don't want the
president to do this Congress has to
vote on this only Congress has this
power now it certainly says that the
Constitution but Congress has an
exercise that power since nineteen forty
one I mean this is and they know this
and so they sort of seemed to switch
sides in this debate this philosophical
point of how much power the president
was in a Democratic president they
wanted to have all this power and they
feared taking away and it's a Republican
present then suddenly they
they're all about Congress and it struck
me as sort of obviously an overtly
partisan and I I don't think historians
ought to be doing that I think they
ought to be doing what what journalists
are trying to do which is attempt to be
fair and objective you can't always do
that but you try and so but i but I give
them oh the mildest of shots i mean the
books as you point out pretty positive
but then even after saying that i go on
to say that some of these historians
help me very people are criticized and
in fact as I got into the writings
because you have to read you know
William Lee Miller and James Macpherson
McCullough will answer you have to read
these people to do a book like this and
their their scholarship and the writing
is so impressive and their commitment to
these kids because they're all these
people are still teaching classes you
know most about the undergraduate level
and so I came away actually with this
great respect for them even though I was
irritated going in so how often did you
call a historian Oh constantly I mean
who was the most helpful oh they're also
helpful but everybody I asked was
helpful Frank Grizzard of the papers of
George Washington was just wonderful but
I hate to single one person every single
person I called was helpful it was there
was a there's a fellow I forget his name
right now he wrote a book about Robert
Gould Shaw and the Massachusetts 54th
the integrated regiment that well the
black regiment and he would he
disappeared he was I didn't know I
couldn't find him it i sent out sort of
an all call you know an email and he
writes back from from copenhagen he's if
he's in denmark and i wanted to know
what this is the kind of thing you know
you get fixed on did did shaw really
sing the john brown him as they marched
into Harpers Ferry he implies that in
his book he never quite says it so he
called yeah I left that let her out but
yes he did and that's the kind of help i
got it was just wonderful you dedicate
this book to two men yeah and i'll read
it the book is dedicated to the memories
of michael kelly a journalist and a
friend into a gallant young man from
Massachusetts first lieutenant
Brian and mcphillips us united states
marine corps why those two men well they
were friends of mine Brian Brian was a
family friend a young I'm really friends
with his parents and he went to
Providence College enlisted the Marine
Corps and went to Iraq and Michael Kelly
of course was a well-known Washington
journalist and and he went to Iraq and
and I was worried about both of them and
I actually said some prayers for them
and they both died there killed within
24 hours of each other and it was a very
sad time at our magazine Ashland journal
and very sad time for the mcphillips
family up in Massachusetts and I just I
thought that this would I felt like
doing it because there's nothing else I
could do for them I wish there was
something I could do for the families
and but they both got this idea they
they were they were happy warriors and
for the right reason Brian my wife sent
Brian's mother I clipping it was in The
Washington Post he may have seen about
this a woman in Iraq who had been raped
and brutalized by Saddam secret police
and her husband had been killed for no
reason that they marry she married a man
from India and this in Saddam's Iraq
that was a capital offense and wife sent
this clipping to to Brian mcphillips
mother and she said and she said well
that made her feel better she said Brian
Brian loved women and Brian wouldn't
this is what Brian would have been
trying to stop there so
one of the in pursuit of happiness in
war you go through a lot of background
on how many people in this country have
been killed yeah and you went into some
detail I mean World War two for instance
you broke it down well actually in front
of his civil war yeah you broke that
down those who were actually killed in
combat and killed by other causes coming
up to a grand total of about 650 9052
deaths both North and South during the
Civil War you did the same thing when it
came to the world war two what why well
the in slavery had to be ended and
Lincoln knew it and it was ended but it
wasn't the cost was so frightful to
people that after that war was over most
Americans I don't think questioned that
the cause was just but what they
question was war itself and the Civil
War I believe started or helped foment a
deep strain of pacifism in America in
within America and so you know we're a
warlike country in some ways but we also
have this experience now that all of the
European powers have had now we
understand really how how costly war is
after the Civil War it's the first
modern war really and ever since then in
a run up to a war there's been a very
fierce debate and I have a chapter on on
the on this this strain that pacifism
really is what it's about but and I
don't mean that in a pejorative way I
mean the people you know we really think
that war is so eat so horrible the cost
of it that we should always try and find
some other way and I you know the book
sort of advocates extension of these
rights even by arms if necessary but
it's been it's been extended by other
ways there I finally had to write about
some other leaders other than wartime
presence
Frederick Douglass and Martin Luther
King and Elizabeth Cady Stanton and
martin luther king who pursued the
extension of rights through peaceful
means to and they also employ these
people the language of the preamble of
the Declaration and they have as good a
claim to it as a wartime president I
think how often did you find these words
pursuit of happiness well and the
Jefferson words and they actually from
the decoration their constant but what I
was looking for was more not just people
sort of using it as a throw a line but
people using it to make their case and
which Martin Luther King did when he
came the United States and he said those
words were a promissory note and I'm
we're here to collect on that note and
it was used in that direct fashion and
in fact well Frederick Frederick
Douglass would n lincoln used those
words constantly and in a time when
within it the abolition movement there
were sort of two there were two schools
one was led by william lloyd garrison
who thought that the document the
Declaration and the Constitution these
two documents in our little booklet were
tainted because they've been written by
slave holders and they and they seemed
to the Constitution sort of incorporated
slavery into the governing structures of
the Senate and he burned the
constitutional declaration in a famous
speech and said they're they're pacts
with the devil he was a secessionist
from the other side but Douglas argued
and Lincoln argued that the words
themselves were so powerful and their
meaning so obvious that the sins of the
people who wrote them was secondary and
that we didn't need a new government we
just needed to live up to the Creed of
the Declaration and that debate was
within abolition was won by Lincoln and
Frederick Douglass and and so they have
used those words and so that's the kind
of thing I exploring that I'm not so
interested in people you know of a
parade just using the phrase I'm
interested in how the words came to be
understood by Americans as obliging them
to grant freedom to other people what
was your reaction when he found ho chi
minh using them I was delighted where
did you find whatever you I wish I could
remember Brian that was just one of one
of those things you come across and you
can't hardly believe it's even true i
don't speak vietnamese and his lang is
speech ho chi minh used his speech 1954
used our language and in fact set it up
like Jefferson you went in the course of
human events kind of speech but I called
a scholar who written about a whole team
in biographer and he said yeah that ho
Chi Minh had done this and he done it
deliberately to try and show the
Americans that they didn't that this
they didn't want to pick up the mantle
of French colonialism that that wasn't
true to our our traditions that our true
tradition would be to support the desire
of the Vietnamese people to be free of
colonialism now's guess it worked for a
while but obviously it didn't really
work because we went over there anyway
did what was it what happened to you
Jimmy what happened to you during this
period of research how long did you
research about a year what happened to
your whole perception of the Declaration
of Independence and this preamble over
that time and the attitude that you
found people i had about it didn't
change me in a way a tree but it
reinforced something that and that is
there all of a very big tent view of
patriotism not and i did before but it
but the Ho Chi Minh I in one chapter
with ho chi minh and begin the next one
with john mccain now talk to him yeah
yeah and mccain mccain is one of the few
non presidents thing that i did I talked
about there because he's an important
figure to me I mean I think in this
world he and he writes about how being
in prison in the North Vietnamese
prisoner of war camp helped him really
understand America's values and and
really helped him become the fully
patriotic American and he's a guy who
throws sides in Washington even in this
polarized tally he's a person who
commands respect across the spectrum
and one of the reasons why is his he has
a good sense of country and people
respect that and he's paid the price but
he also helped lead the opening to
Vietnam he's not vindictive he's not
he's very old school but he's also very
modern in his thinking but what it but
the answer your question is I realize
how I realized that people arguing now
their petty little squabbles have little
patience for that I don't think much of
it matters I think what matters are the
big things and I think that these and
like I said these presidents and these
immigrants who think that America is
still special and that we have special
obligations I I came to believe that's
right who's the happiest person you know
that's a good question hmm
I don't know I don't know my books full
of happy people that some of them are
dead and are you happier knowing all
that you know from now that you've
studied this history intensely or will
you be better off if you're just
ignorant of all no no I think if you
read this book people can win i think
well alright America is going to be okay
we make a lot of mistakes but we're
going to be okay we're heading in the
right direction why why are we headed in
the right direction and are we different
than others well I don't know if
Americans are different than other
people but this country has a different
as a history it's a you realize your
eyes why it's so difficult for the
Palestinian state to take shape because
because the organizing what are the
organizing principles of it well they
want land they want to be they want to
the one of their own country where they
don't have to you know go to through
Israeli checkpoints and that's not a
small thing I I'm sure but what are the
principles what are the great principles
and this country was founded on some
great principles and if we're true to
them if we're true to them the whole
world's better off that's to me an
optimistic message did you find people
misusing this concept hey you know I
went into there yeah but I would Calhoun
and his son and well calhoun was a you
know a racist and an opportunist but he
didn't really miss use it he did the
sure some of these the southern
secessionist you know that even they
didn't misuse it they just said
Jefferson was wrong well I don't think
he was wrong lincoln in think is wrong
but no i don't it's hard to misuse and
people have a right to use them any way
they want they have as much right to
those words as i do so what do you want
people to learn from this book I mean
how much of it is the history of it what
could you do you go into some you know a
lot of corners in this book yeah I
well and you quote and you make a point
that you quote a lot of people
extensively well then how did you do
that well because you know we well I
bend it I've bend it like presidential
conferences even academics even let
alone Nightly News where people are
talking about presidential
communications how present communicates
and then they won't really quote the
president they'll give a little snip at
a word hear a word they're you know it's
commonly said by some bushes political
adversaries today that Bush never talked
about human rights in Iraq he only
talked about weapons of mass destruction
for instance well that's flatly and
correct he talked about human rights in
Iraq as a reason for war probably a
hundred times but he wasn't quoted very
much we don't really quote presents the
way we used to in the way we should and
so in my book I thought well that's
unsatisfactory if I'm writing about how
presence and words moved a nation I
don't have a chunk of the quote and
maybe I went a little too far with that
I don't know but I those quotes are
powerful these presidents tend to be
pretty articulate when they're talking
about freedom after you finish this book
who would you put on the top of your
list of people you respect the most of
the presidents no just everybody I mean
the whole we need well some of the
things you know I mean who would be your
favorite look you know Babe Ruth really
could have hit you know the conventional
wisdom isn't always wrong Lincoln was
great George Washington was great but
you mentioned babe ruth and that's an
important part of your whole concept
here baseball baseball why baseball
baseball something that makes me happy
and i use it because it's a frame of
reference I don't even know if it's
still the national pastime at pranna
that's basketball today or pro football
but but Bush used it and Giuliana used
it in these pictures of the of the 911
of Giuliani as Yankees uniforms at the
game stuck in people's mind so it's a
frame of reference to help George
Washington you point out George
Washington played played catch at Valley
Forge for hours what they call it fives
fives we're different names it sort of
derived from rounders but it's a it's
evolved steadily here Abner Doubleday
tonight invent baseball i guess where i
can say that on this show he didn't
so again you look back the people in
here that you want to read more about
did you well well there are so many I
mean all right the obvious ones you know
Roosevelt linka George Washington
Jefferson I mean Jefferson and Adams you
know I don't there's a great fight going
on to this day the New England people of
atoms and things to get short shrift and
think Jefferson was a slaveholding
racist and that Virginians think
Jefferson was the brightest man ever
walked the planet well I don't have to
choose between them I like them both
from California um but but there's some
other great people that we don't
remember Calvin Coolidge never really
said the business of America is business
not really what he was talking about was
to newspaper writers and he was telling
them but he that I knew he knew they
needed to make money but he trusted
newspaperman to always put the public
good ahead of business that's what he
really said a Hoover who you know to
this day you go to a Jackson Jefferson
Dave dinner some whom Democrat who wants
to be present old rag on Hoover but
Hoover was a great man who gave his
whole life to public service and saved
millions of people from starvation one
guy one man I think I think Carter is an
underrated present that you know people
laugh at me in the city when I say that
but I for my lights he got it you know I
I think I think Reagan really was
reagan's sort of unembarrassed promotion
of freedom around the world I think will
be remembered long you know not in the
sneering way that today's intellectuals
okay but is a great thing what are
what's a young person to think when they
pick up your book and read this quote
quote well I'm talking to you mothers
and fathers I give you more assurance
FDR told the cheering crowd I have said
this before but I'll say it again and
again and again your boys are not going
to be sent into any foreign wars well
and that's 1940 campaign right right
it's October of 1940 window Wilkie's
listening on the radio and says
he's costing the election right is that
well what's a young person thing they I
hope they got to read the whole chapter
because what I'm using that is I'm not
trying to make Roosevelt into a
disingenuous guy what I'm trying to do
in that chapter is show that there's
this natural tension candidates for
president are very leery of war even a
candidate is already present but
presidents are also commanders in chief
and then they begin to see the reason
that they may have to go to war and
that's a very natural tension and I
offer it I hope that young people will
be reassured and that this debate we're
having about bush and Iraq which at
times it's very vitriolic to vitriolic
for my taste but it's a healthy debate
and it's the debate to have and for
prefer for a candidate to say well yeah
well I wouldn't get involved net foreign
war that's he's responding to this path
of a strain in American because it's a
country that understands how awful war
can be in the cost and these people who
died like Young Brian but the commander
chief gets in and understands that if
that if the Kurds are to be free or or
the Germans or the Japanese are the
Filipinos or Chinese there's nobody else
to do it and so it weighs heavily on it
so presidents tend to be more martial
and candidates more peace-loving but
that's a very healthy dichotomy in the
middle of all this you did this book
also yeah I did one third of that book
I've been very busy but one one of the
offers authors of this book boy genius
about Karl Rove is a man named Lou do
bosun he's got another bestseller out
right now which is not exactly positive
on George Bush is that that we know
their book but there's only you know
there's these books out you know we live
in these times i mean the you know the
book what are some of the titles you
know so-and-so is a big fat liar george
bush neighbors told the truth in his
life you know lies lies lies lies lies
and then the other side that's the
left-wing and right-wing all democrats
are traitors you know they've always
been traitors traitor treason this
book's my books not like that out
like that that's not how I see things
boy genius is about poor genius about
Karl Rove but you know and I I got no
quarrel with Lou he's a good guy but I
think my third of the book reads a
little different oh I think that's fair
to say the tone of a soul different
would you think of writing this book
well it was it was sort of a labor of
love I just really had something I
wanted to say I don't know if I said it
well or not but I think I think I'm onto
something I I hope people will read it
and have you kids ready um my son's
reading it now it's just out you know
how old he's 23 just turned 23 wants to
go to law school it's now he's
interested in constitutional law he said
anything about the book that you want to
repeat no I think he was a little
surprised the old men thought deep
thoughts this is the cover of the book
it's called the pursuit of happiness in
times of war and our guest is Carl
cannon White House correspondent for the
National Journal thank you very much
thank you